hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game that was played at the 1958
interzonal on the wide end many time
Argentine Champion Raul sanguinetti he
won the Argentine Championship twice
before this game
and he would go on to win it five more
times
his opponent 15 year old Bobby Fisher
okay opening wise we have an open
Sicilian
nidorf
and F4 upon Duo after these six moves
I have a pop quiz for you
there's something I noticed about this
game after going through it two or more
times
something stuck out to me and I'm
wondering if you could maybe pick up on
the same scent
so I'm just going to throw it to you
like this not the most common question
to be sure here it goes
what does sanguinetti do on more than
one occasion that fisher does not do
through the first 20 moves of the game
this is only a 25 move game if you're
wondering
okay we're going to come back to that
question
where do we go from here in this game
upon Duo is present good strategy
challenge it E5 on board challenge it
immediately
okay Knight F3 is the reply increasing
the pressure on this point how should
you defend E5 here how would you defend
E5 feel free to pause the video
okay here we go
Queen C7 multi-purpose move watch over
E5 and watch
that this guy doesn't get on this
diagonal
Queen has that square Comfort now
so you don't get that if you simply
develop the Knight to one of these two
squares
Queen C7 factors in
the bishop move to C4
if it is allowed to get on this diagonal
do no it is
eyeing up the weakest Square in Black's
Camp D5
alright from here Bishop D3
Knight B to D7 I believe this is the
uh
optimal post for the queen Knight
for a couple reasons
one is that with this tension at any
point
F takes e can be in there and a white
Rook we could foresee
uh one day exerting pressure on the f
file on the file squares F6 in
particular
well the queen Knight is there
reinforcing this point now
also if we throw under the microscope
the other option for the queen Knight C6
something you must factor in playing on
the black side here is the weakest
Square D5 you have to anticipate at some
point this Knight dropping into that
point
what's going to happen when the Knight
arrives there you pretty much have to
get rid of it
it's usually an intolerable piece
how's that going to look how is your
queen Knight going to feel when it's on
C6
take on D5 the pawn recaptures what is
that pawn doing it's attacking your
knight do you have a good reply to that
attack you should have an answer to
those questions before making the
decision to go to C6
at the end of the day in this one the
knights are Simply Connected the king
side
strengthened
from here castles
B5
white is drifting towards the king side
these are two appealing squares for the
queen
and Bishop to B7 notice as soon as the
bishop leaves this diagonal this is
where white says you know what
that F5 square is looking extra
sensitive
you're not there controlling that square
anymore
okay the computer is a fan in this
position of
staying flexible in a way
making a useful
move getting the King off of this opened
diagonal
not yet committing
to Knight H4
but in this game white goes straight for
this sensitive point
on F5
black cuts that one out
this is under control but at the same
time weaknesses are now present on the
king's side white says mission
accomplished I got what I wanted I
provoked weaknesses so the Knight
Returns towards the center
Bishop G7
Queen H4 kingside castles F takes e d
takes e and Bishop H6 trying to remove
a key defender on the king side
Knight H5
cuts off the queen from defending the
bishop Bishop takes Bishop
King takes Bishop follows who is the one
who really benefits here because of that
exchange I believe
it's really turning out to be black
if there isn't a good follow-up
attacking wise for white it's this
positional
um idea that I think is fact or uh
favoring team black in this case what
just happened there with that exchange
we exchanged
good for bad Bishop
judging by this Central structure and
what remains
black has this better Bishop in this
current position
all right from here Rook a to D1
additionally with no dark Square Bishops
around look at this square right here
F4 black hops right to it and does so
only knowing that there isn't a good
tactic here
for why
what tactic am I talking about
in the game Rook F2 is played what's
going to happen though if Knight takes
E5 this is something Fisher had to First
calculate before applying Knight to F4
what am I going to do if the defender of
my knight is captured
what is the best reply
if white is capturing in this way
feel free to pause the video
okay there's only one winning move and
it is
Knight takes on G2
that's not a one point Pawn that's a two
point Pawn
this is considered a winning position
now for team black
let's say King takes Knight Knight takes
Knight
fantastic position here for black
even a an end game a position where
there are no Queens on board is
considered a decisive Advantage this
Knight is worth far more
then three black has a great piece here
with the Knight on E5 a better structure
a better Bishop
any other continuation
uh in this position I believe one of the
moves was Queen E7 at this stage
and even this position right here is
considered winning for black
fantastic piece on E5 in all cases
so Knight takes E5 is met with Knight
takes G2
Rook F2 in this game
F6 so forget about these tricks working
now black would simply recapture with a
pawn and this is secure the Pawn With
The Rook
from here Rook on F to D2 doubling on
the
opened D file
from here Knight C5
Bishop to F1 and B4 so those are the 20
moves so let's come back to this
question I asked earlier
what does sanguinetti do
on more than one occasion that fisher
does not do through these first 20 moves
um the answer to that is
uh well sanguinetti Retreats on more
than one occasion Fischer did not
retreat at all up until this point
those add up I believe it's not the only
contributor to this uh
decisive Advantage now for black but
it plays a role he never retreated he
was always in the forward
there was only actually there was only
one move so far by black where he wasn't
moving forward but it was still a move
that was making progress that was when
he castled
every move though by Fisher these first
20 moves forward moves
I should note that this last move by
white is a losing move
the only way to really stay in the game
in the computer's eyes is to secure this
Knight to flick in A3 so the Knight is
not scared away
okay but in this game after Bishop F1
and B4
this is already
basically a lost position now the Knight
goes into D5 Bishop takes Knight still
continuing to move forward
Pawn takes Bishop
a winning position now for black
continues to move forward look at these
Knights
two nights in White's camp
completely crushing this Rook is
completely out of squares now the
knights cover all squares from the D2
Rook there's no fear of any pawn advance
black still has these checks to get out
of that
black is winning material this is now a
one game now this idea of sanguinetti
making retreating moves Fisher didn't
make any retreating moves
that's not the only thing that factors
into this decisive position right now I
believe this play on the king side
by white was easily addressed the
exchange of dark Square Bishops I
believe ended up just favoring black and
in in the end if there isn't a good
follow-up what is this queen doing over
here on H4 she's a bit just
in left field she's not a great
contributor additionally three Tempe
were invested by white to double Rooks
like this once they were in direct
connection with one another but where
are they really going from here
they really don't want to be staring at
the back of a pond like this they want
to have that file opened up so
there's a lot of things that stick out
to me those are just some of them I
wanted to share with you
now we have a decisive advantage
loss of material coming up
from here one more retreating move the
queen goes back but again by this point
it's simply lost there was no way to
save The Rook
black is now up the exchange
Queen takes Knight
and that right there is the only
retreating
move by Fisher but it is a best move in
this case he has a tactic up his sleeve
he's saying if you take my knight
I'm gonna hit you with the skewer
and win your Rook
so what does white play he goes with C4
and this does open up the B3 Square so
in in this position after Queen takes
Knight Rook here this tactic wouldn't be
there if
now this Pawn wasn't on C2 because the
queen could come back and be defending
the Rook
with C4 in this position
uh White is threatening to maybe take
the Knight and come back here but Fisher
at this point simply captures on C3 on
poisson and says if you take my knight
it's fine I'm not gonna get your Rook
but I'm going to have a one position
anyhow I'm going to have a passed Pawn
after this last move B takes C3 white
simply resigns
what's the story in this position if
Queen takes Knight and Rook a to d8 and
queen B3 in this case defending the Rook
black could simply exchange Rooks and
then take on B2 completely winning
position the imbalance here is a rook in
three Pawns versus the two miners but
soon enough one of these pieces will
have to be sacrificed to stop this Pawn
from promoting I'll just give one sample
line if the game continued from this
point let's say Bishop there there's
Queen C1
there's Rook 2 C8 these aren't the very
best moves but it gets the job done
you could have the exchange of Queens
and you could simply promote straight
away and win the bishop like this and of
course completely winning from here
but in this one after B takes C3 on
poisson white throws in the towel
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away that's
all for now take care bye
thank you